viajando a través de pequeñas carreteras
rurales para llegar a la línea del
frente ucraniano esta es la base del
batallón carpas casyc' situada al sur de
hizo una ciudad ahora en manos de los
rusos la unidad formada por unos pocos
cientos de hombres tiene la misión de
destruir los blindajes rusos
los tanques no tienen ninguna
posibilidad contra esto si le dan a la
torreta no quedará nada de ella si sabes
usar las armas con un buen instructor
puedes aprender rápidamente
[Música]
carpa de cachiche es uno de los muchos
batallones nacionalistas nacidos del
movimiento de protesta de maidán de 2014
ahora se ha integrado en el ejército
ucraniano el batallón trabaja para
bloquear el avance de rusia en las zonas
del noroeste del donbass pero su líder
dice que occidente tiene que hacer mucho
más
hay un constante fuego de artillería
sobre nuestras posiciones los tanques
también nos disparan pero resistimos
necesitamos más armas antitanques quiero
enviar un mensaje a todos los países
occidentales necesitamos ayuda tenemos
armas pero necesitamos más ayúdennos a
derrotar a nuestro enemigo jurado que
está atacando los cimientos del mundo
civilizado
vamos date prisa
los drones rusos sobrevuelan la zona
para guiar los ataques mientras suenan
las explosiones cercanas algunos
residentes se resguardan y otros no se
asustan en absoluto nos hemos
acostumbrado lleva dos veces sucediendo
pero no se refugian si a veces cuando se
pone muy duro sólo los tontos no tienen
miedo
unos minutos más tarde los golpes
empiezan a acercarse
cubran sí
si tuviéramos armas más potentes
podríamos contraatacar por el momento no
tenemos demasiadas bajas tratamos de
mantener nuestras posiciones y evitar
que avancen nos veíamos costumbres en
otros
cuando terminan las explosiones hay una
tregua alrededor de la unidad varios
tanques como estos de 72 de la época
soviética se camuflan bajo el collage o
fechas no y viene unos dos tribus pero
nuestro armamento es demasiado viejo
para luchar en una guerra moderna
necesitamos la artillería y los tanques
que tienen los países de la otan eso es
lo que soñamos lo necesitamos para ganar
esta guerra
antes de que los ucranianos puedan
cantar victoria tienen que salvar el
donbass pero esto no será una hazaña
fácil el ejército sólo tiene una pequeña
parte de la región ahora